hallo herzlich willkommen in den
heimatorten welt heute gibt es mal
wieder leckere schnitte von mehr und
zwar eine sommerliche himbeer stimmte
zwar weile mutter morand mich manchmal
durchschnitte na ja auf jeden fall
gezogen ihrem bett und ich zeige euch
jetzt gleich die zutaten also es wird so
sein dass ich so eine leckere weicher
teig dann kommt ein putting schicht rein
und dann die himbeer schicht ich mag
halt ein ganz besonders gerne wenn ihr
jetzt aber sagt ich würde gerne ein
anderes ob stoffe nehmen können
natürlich auch ein anderes obst nehmen
als etwa heidelberg
was auch immer für sich also alles was
euch halten das ding kommt und ich zeige
ich jetzt erstmal die zutaten für treib
und später für die andere schichten also
ich brauche dafür drei eier 100 gramm
zucker 100 milliliter mineralwasser 100
milliliter öl 100 gramm mehl 50 gramm
stärke enthalten eine halbe packung
backpulver und etwas vanille extrakt und
ich starte jetzt auch direkt mit dem
teig und gibt dafür die eier jetzt in
die rührschüssel da kommt der zucker mit
dazu und ich gehe gleich noch eine prise
salz mit dazu habe ich jetzt vergessen
herauszustellen
das ist einfach mal schaumig rühren
und wenn das ganze dann schön weiß
schaumig und cremig ist gebe ich noch
mal extra dazu kann man auch direkt zu
anfang mit reihen gebe aber das habe ich
vergessen dann die zwei flüssigkeiten
also wasser und öl und das wird jetzt
nur noch bei niedriger stufe
untergerührt was einmal ganz kurz
das reicht schon und dann kann ich den
rest nämlich mit einem schneebesen
einfach unterheben und das liebe ich
jetzt vorher kurz durch einfach
speisestärke backpulver und mehl dann
gibt es auch keine klümpchen im teig und
das vermischt sich auch schön
miteinander jetzt nur noch kein zeichen
unterheben
und den teig gebe ich dann in meine
backform und zwar habe ich jetzt hier
bereits mit back haben zurecht gelegt
sag ich jetzt mal auf meine back folie
und meinen backblech und habs auf 26 x
26 cm eingestellt und wenn ihr das gerne
größere klettern wollte das einfach ein
bisschen rechnen
das würde jetzt auch gut in eine
springform reinpassen mit dem
durchmesser 28 cm und ansonsten habe ich
eine umrechnung tabelle auf meinem blog
könnte da reinschauen und euch das ganz
einfach um rechnen
und so wie der kuchen jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
und unterhitze für ungefähr 35 minuten
gebacken und danach lassen wir ihn
komplett abkühlen main baskets jetzt
abgekühlt und jetzt kann ich die pudding
creme herstellen und dafür brauche ich
nur ganz wenige zutaten
natürlich kann man jetzt auch im pudding
aus der tüte nehmen aber das braucht man
absolut gar nicht denn der pudding aus
der tüte hat auch noch stärker mit drin
eventuell noch bedingt farbstoff und
aroma und das können wir hier alles
umgehen indem wir einfach nur die vier
zutaten nehmen und zwar habe ich hier
500 milliliter milch 50 g speisestärke
40 zucker und ich nehme noch mein
vanille extrakt denn das schmeckt
nämlich wirklich nach wanninger weiß ja
auch echte vanille und jetzt nämlich
zuerst mal die milch gibt die in den
topf nochmals gleich alles zusammen dann
kommt da die speisestärke noch mit rein
das höre ich jetzt einmal schön glas
damit die klümpchen weg sind
so ganz schnell dann der zucker noch mit
rein und ein bisschen man extrakt
schrecke ich jetzt mal damit sich das
vanille merke dass ein bisschen verteilt
da gebe ich jetzt ja schon einen halben
teelöffel rein weil es so jan richtig
wann illegal in putin halt werde dann
schalte ich jetzt dein herz an und lass
das ganze einfach mal aufkochen
und wenn es dann aufgekocht ist können
das einfach vom herd runter nehmen dann
ist schon richtig schön eingedeckt und
da müsste einfach aufpassen wenn wir
euch die gefahr besteht dass der pudding
zu schnell an brennt am topfboden dann
gibt den zucker einfach zum schluss erst
mit dazu dann passiert ist nämlich nicht
so schnell so und jetzt gehe ich einfach
den warmen tee oder den heißen pudding
besser gesagt auf den abgekühlten teig
und dann einfach so ein bisschen
verteilen am besten mit so einer kleinen
winkel palette
und dann lasse ich das jetzt einfach nur
mal komplett abkühlen und danach kommt
dann erst mit drauf also ich lasse es
kurz bei raumtemperatur stehen gibt es
dann in den kühlschrank und wenn es ganz
kalt und ganz glatt ist also ganz
kritisch ganz klar im schnitt tanz
comedy himbeere mit drauf und dann
machen wir gleich fertig während der
vanillepudding jetzt noch abkühlt wenn
ich schon mal den tortenguss herstellt
und dafür brauche ich nur drei zutaten
und zwar habe ich hier 20 gramm zucker
einfach dass ein bisschen süßer wird 65
g speisestärke 750 milliliter saftig
habe ich hier einen kirschsaft ihr könnt
ihn besser haft oder irgendein anderes
saft nehme und 750 gramm gefroren
himbeeren und hier ist jetzt genauso wie
beim putting also ich gebe zins saft
hier rein bei steht erstmal ein teil
rein
ich habe wisse gekleckert früher die
stärke jetzt hier kurz ein
damit es nicht so plump welcher weise
bisschen mehr stärke für das jetzt glatt
und dann gebe ich den restlichen
betreuen und so könnt ihr euch im
prinzip auch den torf sparen bei dem
prinzip ich hatte auch nur stärke mit
drin
man könnte jetzt auch mit agile zum
beispiel machen das ist die pflanzliche
variante der gelatine
allerdings wird es ein bisschen
langsamer festlich stärke man kann auch
schneller viele benutzen
aber auch da ist so dass es einfach
etwas länger braucht zum fest werden
jetzt koche ich das kurz auf und gibt
dann den zucker zum schluss ein schmied
dazu da muss man aufpassen dass jetzt
das am topfboden wieder also an trend
ist schon mal abgebrannt
habe ich mich selber verraten durch
meinen wieder
naja jetzt ist
jetzt gebe ich den zucker noch mit rein
und rührt es einfach nur mal schön durch
und es darf jetzt so person halbe minute
etwa aufkochen
länger braucht es gar nicht wen ich das
jetzt mit akademie zum beispiel macht
also mit agar agar dann müsste das zwei
minuten einkochen lassen
und wenn ihr es mit gelatine macht
müsste die stadt ihnen entweder vorher
ein weichen also die blatt gelatine und
dann einfach in die heiße masse mit
reingeben nicht kochen lassen oder ihr
nehmt die gelatine die gemahlin müsste
quellen lassen und die dann auch nur in
die heiße somit rein gehen und auch
nicht kochen so ist jetzt fertig kann
ich ausschalten und kohl kurz meinen
kuchen auf dem kühlschrank hier verteile
ich jetzt die kalten himbeeren drüber
wir können natürlich auch frische
hinnehmen aber tief gefroren habe ich
halt immer zu hause und schließt ihn
immer schnell griffbereit und die gebe
ich jetzt darauf mir wird jetzt auch
noch einfall man könnte den kuchen auch
feldkirchen machen kann auch die aus dem
glas einfach nehmen und dann da denkt
ihr stoff benutzen
aber ich finde sich halt mit ihm werse
richtig lecker
jetzt gebe ich hier einfach löffelweise
den guss drauf visuelle schneller weil
durch die himbeeren wird der ghost auch
relativ schnell fest und einfach schön
verteilen und das riecht hat richtig
lecker also jetzt riecht es nach himbeer
und nach kirschen
das ist echt gut
und so stelle ich jetzt dieses heiße
schnittchen in den kühlschrank
da kann es nämlich komplett abkühlen und
ich denke so in etwa einer halben stunde
bis stunde dürfte die masse da oben
drauf fest sein und dann können wir den
kuchen auch gleich anschneiden und
probieren und ich freue mich schon
richtig drauf denn die wird also die
schnitte wird richtig lecker geht ganz
schnell
die hütte ist jetzt schön kalt und jetzt
kann sie angeschnitten werden
zuerst muss ich jetzt aber diesen
tortenring mal lösen
und jetzt kann ich das einfach schön
klein schneiden ich denke ich mache
jetzt einfach 16 stücke daraus markiert
es jetzt erst mal die hälfte da die
hälfte
und dann kann es durch schneiden
und dann entweder noch ein bisschen grün
damit auch hübsch aussieht minister
passt da sowieso gut dazu
und fertig ist ein leckeres im bei
schnittchen
ich habe ein stück muss ich jetzt sogar
probieren oder die karima probiert
romane wie ich gespannt wie lange auf
diesen moment gewartet heute also ich
würde mir auch gerne probieren aber ihr
wisst ihr ich probiere jetzt auch gern
vor der kamera
bei mir gibt keiner übergehen schmeckt
gut oder effekte temperatur der teig ist
super der pudding also da passe ich
alles an der einfahrt nach was aber kein
chili eine tasse kaffee und ein häufchen
sahne astra lecker das machen wir uns
jetzt aber ihr dürft gerne jetzt schon
mal das rezept nachlesen auf salis -
blog.de und am besten paktiert es auch
direkt nach denn ich finde die torte
auch super lecker ich habs jetzt zwar
noch nicht probiert aber das macht
gleich aber er sieht schon mal ziemlich
richtig frucht dich aus und ich habe
mich schon echt schon mal auf die himba
schnelle gefreut
naja ok wir genießen das jetzt gleich zu
einer tasse kaffee und zu einem häufchen
sahne und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachbacken und wir sehen uns
dann ganz einfach beim nächsten mal
wieder biss dann tschüss